so I suppose we should start off by
saying I got some good news and bad news
it's been decided apparently I wasn't my
choice but Danny Machuca is gonna start
taking over most of the Monday night
class some of people have been here
perhaps you've seen it he's done two of
them now which means I'm still gonna try
to do the opening cuz I'm just gonna
have to like fight and be like come on
yeah let me do my openings I'll probably
do a bunch of top 10s like I got some
stuff in the works but this is not a
joke I want to tell you what Danny is
doing so you have to be here because he
doesn't want to tape you just want to be
on YouTube that's fine a 16 part series
this is not a joke I'm the nimzo-indian
people you've both been there you've
been there right some decisive games a
few so here week 1 was his game some
game from like 1912 nimzowitsch anyone
wolf draw it was ok at the beginning and
you know but you know he's like just as
a draw it was a draw a perfect game so
you expect a lot of that on Monday night
we'll try to try to convince them to
tape it
but today in sort of Danny's honor I
thought we'd find a draw I'd go just for
him but we'll look at an exciting one so
this is a game that's often called the
immortal draw because it's so
spectacular and this is the game between
Carl hamp and Philip Michener and it was
played in Vienna 1870 so this is the
Romantic era where people were sacking
their pieces and there was wild
swashbuckling attacks and okay whenever
somebody sacked the pieces people would
always accept and all right those games
from that period are usually fantastic
normally now people defend better so but
uh but ok it's fun to watch and even
though this game was a draw up Danny's
favorite it was very exciting
so people that like to see some
spectacular chess should be excited
about this game as well ok the game
began rather normally and now we have
the Vienna game ok not the most popular
move but
certainly not a bad choice Bishop c5
again not the most popular move but you
know that's it's fine
and now a strange move Knight to a4 and
not a very popular move so okay I mean
now every beginner in every book and
every video always says don't move the
same piece twice in the opening and this
is no exception so already a strange
move it's only been played about 20
times or so but it does lead to some
wild and crazy complications because
black in a nice aggressive romantic
spirit decided I'm gonna go in for this
sacrifice so already you know move 3 we
got some fireworks on the board and
what's this all about I mean is this is
this just a piece okay in comes the
Queen and so I already White has to make
some some tough decisions here you
really don't want to play a move like g3
because after we take here we're forking
both of these pieces so I mean okay what
are you gonna do and a brave brave man
the white king decided to step up and
defend the pond as you would do is just
look like all of your games no well you
don't have your King on e3 by mu five
add a few moves yeah so fantastic stuff
yep it's like I'm up a piece but the
compensation is it's pretty obvious the
King is already running around in comes
a little check okay I scoot over and
black obviously wants to really open up
the position and crush the white king
before white ever gets all of his pieces
out so in a dream world you know the
King has to go find safety somewhere and
we got to get our pieces out and we're
up a piece d5 so real aggressive trying
to open it up there's obviously a pin
here so we're not just taking on d5 and
okay I guess I guess I'll ask the class
what you guys would play in this
position cuz it's already you know every
move here is pretty critical when you're
you're running around with your king
you got to play very accurately so black
just played d5 and now it's White's turn
so does anybody have any ideas Queen f3
okay
interesting move we'll go ahead and have
a have a quick look at this
unfortunately it looks like I can just
take here and okay you have to take with
your queen right and then eyes I just
was I can snatch this or I can even
consider playing this move here so that
was not quite it
protect what
take the pun okay how are you gonna
protect it
Queen e2 okay so I mean initially it
does look slightly clumsy some of the
placement of some of your pieces but
okay you you protected your pawn I
suppose I'll just make a normal look and
move and sometimes I play Knight to b4
sometimes I take on e4 and then have
some tricks it seems it seems alright
but I don't know I still got kind of
prefer black just goes in general
principle you know I don't want to put
this look how clumsy I mean all these
pieces are okay so not not quite what
was played was played in the game was a
little more accurate so does anybody
Nate's III okay this move is actually a
mistake so but it's very tempting you
take the pieces on the side it's not
doing anything you put it back you
defend but here black has a very strong
move taking on e4 the idea being if you
take back with your knight weep in yo
okay you defend and it's similar to the
other time where we were removing a
defender with with a piece we can take
here and grab this guy and now black is
up upon and the white king is still
embarrassed so black is clearly better
here you're still moving your King
around blacks at least for the moment up
material and I mean with the King still
running around you there's no
compensation here for for white so with
that in mind I mean that's that's
obviously a very tempting move in the
game the King decided okay like just
keep walking and he'd really like to
have a lot of time a three maneuver the
King to a to get all the rest of the
pieces out up a piece
yay so that's what white is trying to do
but okay black said I'll take this
attacking the knight on a four
and in the game you just kept going I
protect my night I'm closer to a two but
he actually missed a good chance here so
for a couple moves for a move or two
that was actually chances missed here by
white white actually has a really good
continuation here
he can go d4 with the idea of just sort
of blocking the connection here and only
then going here and at first blush you
know looks really good for white but
there is a trick it does you know if you
think about black what he's gonna do a
first turn it does appear that maybe
maybe white has made a little blunder
here because Queenie one Forks the king
and the bishop on f1 so I will challenge
the classlist is not the game but I will
challenge the class what would you guys
play here as white because you're in
check and I'm gonna take your bishop and
it's it's quite remarkable so it's
understandable why the player with white
didn't see this continuation because it
does indeed appear like okay what you're
just busted I get my piece back and I'm
still attacking your king and but we
have this move Bishop d2 and it's like
well I mean I take your rook right and
and I'm still attacking your bishop that
feels pretty good for me but
surprisingly after we calmly develop our
piece protect the bishop on f1 now the
rook is protecting it white actually has
two threats in this position the big
threat is check followed by grabbing the
Queen and we also have this threat of
taking on g7 which also wins material
and we get to start harassing the black
king so here white actually would be a
little bit better and okay possibly even
winning in this position because he has
two threats and even though his King his
way up on c3 it's actually white that
has leading development he is up a piece
and he has very good chances to win this
game
this was missed by the player
understandable so d4 was not played but
king b3 also a decent move and black
made a threat
Knight to a6 threatening Queen before
checkmate and once again white had the
opportunity to play d4 but he didn't do
it
and here after d4 if you take back white
can just consider either taking this
knight or simply playing the move a
three and both of those continuations
should be winning for white and okay you
have this idea of just blocking the
connection you give back upon but you
get to freely get all of your whoops get
all your bishops out you didn't realize
this bishop was attacking that pond oh
and it sounds on for Bensimon that's
good but oh yeah so I move like d4 is a
typical sacrifice giving back upon to
get your bishops out and get all your
pieces out really quickly but again it
was missed and played the move a three
and it's it's starting to look pretty
good for white okay I'm gonna play my
knight back to c3 talk to my King away
I'm gonna piece up and here black played
a really radical move which might be a
clue as to to what it is he he does not
want that King to escape you know you
get you get no chance to run away and
consolidate so what moved to black play
in this position
Queen c4 check probably not the best
move
need to see five now I'll take it to you
guys keep giving me your pieces I'll
keep taking them okay we're on the same
page
so it's a really really crazy move and
you put it on the computer and I first
it you know it's like whoa what a
blunder but you give it a little bit of
time and it figures it out and it's uh
it's actually an okay move you know so
crazy what's the craziest move you could
possibly play some people are afraid to
say it
yeah giving away your pieces yeah yeah
yeah but that's not like sacking a
three-point piece you can do better
yeah sakta queen yeah okay
Queen takes tonight the king must come
up the board and again the computer will
tell you yeah let's just crushing it but
uh with Beth's play this should work out
it should work out to be like maybe a
little bit better for white but it's
really really complicated and the point
of this move obviously was the knight
goes to c5 and you're King no longer
gets to escape you must come up you must
keep coming out and there's okay
basically two choices everything ergo b4
b5 sent essentially your two choices and
there is a difference in the game
he went to be four will come back to b5
I just want to show the game so we can
understand the differences so here we go
came to b4 and we'll we'll come back and
see why I came to b5 might be an
improvement and okay I'm attacking your
knight
but Chuck
keep coming just keep coming come all
the way up the board
I'll checkmate you okay you can take the
knight and that's what he did we can
briefly look at this move which leads to
a very very complicated computer forced
mate so I'll just show this line check
Bishop check you can even have that
that's fine I'll go here with ideas of
going here just to illustrate if the
knight goes here just some some move we
pass black is threatening a checkmate
okay you have to go here and you can go
to c5 you can also go to b6 with
checkmate so that's the kind of thing
that he's hoping to do he's trying to
catch the king and a mating net right in
the middle of the board but also okay
you can go here which temporarily
prevents that idea and all right the
computer will find you know some crazy
thing here and it'll it'll find all this
is like forest and it's checkmate and
you know 16 or whatever so the computer
yeah a computer can survive for a pretty
long time but then it eventually gets
itself checkmated which okay I mean you
didn't have to see all that and okay so
I mean if you can't even run away
sometimes you can run away in us a
little bit safer but black actually has
a lot of chances to attack your King
several times and force it and back up
the board so he said alright let's take
your knight you're you're slowly running
out of pieces so you better checkmate me
or force the perpetual here and all
right I'm gonna take your deep on next
so he protected it and the threat now is
b6 and after you move Bishop to d7 so
that's the threat I will challenge the
class to see if they can parry this
threat there's only only one move here
there should be five check which is
excellent so if you play a move like c6
you are weakening certain squares so
this just isn't a very good move because
it gives my King some room and you
surprisingly don't really have any any
checkmating attack after that so he
played the best move okay
I just move over and I still have the
idea of b6 looks looks pretty good
b6 checkmate is a strong threat so again
what is y gonna do about that in which
whispers when you're in check
Oh we'll try it you'll get the sound we
got the sound down there we go if the
sound was off we want to made that joke
welcome somebody somebody's nodding do
you know you just enjoying your joke
okay yeah Ben Simon likes the little
sound it's not really loud they have it
this is like Max can I make it louder
what's that you like it - alright
there's rep c6 excellent yeah the only
way to avoid the immediate checkmate
so that was played but beat six anyway
and okay you got the bishop out of the
way of b5 so now your king can go there
only move Knight takes take the knight
you have to take the knight if you don't
take the knight the threat now is night
to d4 and when you backup b5 with
checkmate and even if you play a move
like King a4 you still play Knight to d4
and you know good good luck stop in that
so okay you have to take the night and
what's I mean you're really running out
of pieces you know just keep taking it
all and I mean how you can check me me
or force a draw with whatever you have
left
well black found Li the best move here
again again you're you're gonna like
this one so at home you may want to
pause I'm gonna give it away
there should be seven check ok what's
this what's that all about well you
can't take it in the game we got in here
and let's see there was a draw so this
is how the game ended let's back up so
the computer if you take this black
please King d7 you do have a check but
uh okay I just move and you really don't
have any useful checks now which
surprisingly can't check here you know
these checks you know all these
strengths none of them do anything so
everything is just well-prepared and
okay just this is this is coming so very
surprising you can't even take it
so you just backed up and here too you
have to go back to c6 and accept the
perpetual because if you go here again
black has a very strong move I'll give
the people at home five seconds to
figure it out you can pause and then
I'll just give it away black can win the
game here with the move Bishop to c4
with the powerful threat of b5 very hard
to stop so okay and so that's how the
game ended they repeated here a few
times and the game ended in a draw we
will go back we'll go back real quick to
this position this decision that white
made here and okay King b5 may look like
it it doesn't make much of a difference
but let's see if we can we can try to
understand how this might be different
if
plays the same way okay so I again the
night goes to e7 where it's protecting
the deep on but now I can play this move
c4 and you'll notice you didn't have
time to play the move a5 with check
which really in the game made it really
difficult the fact that you got this
pawn here made it really difficult for
white to escape you know a lot of lines
so that was quite a useful move for
black so going back to king b5 we have
time to play a move like c4 we're trying
to create an escape route we might take
the knight we might not that doesn't
matter we're up so much material we just
want to not get checkmate it and so here
if d4 you know sort of sealing some of
the door black does you know getting it
to make some really powerful threats at
some point he has to toss this move in
and you know it's looking pretty bad you
know I might have these same same sorts
of threats this is the same sort of
checkmating net I'm trying to get you to
walk into but here I have this move
Queen a for check and again if you just
move over we can take this pawn and
remarkably white gives back the material
and after a few more moves he escapes
and it's actually white that probably
has a slight advantage here nothing over
the top but if white wanted to play for
an advantage he had to see this line
where he gives up his Queen though okay
and then the game would still just be a
fight but as the way the game ended it
truly was an immortal game a very
fantastic draw so okay do you guys have
any questions about the game or anything
no all right well until next time hit
like share subscribe and see you guys
next week